[Music]  President Obama's campaign slogan this  time around in 2012 is forward yeah well  for a while now Vice President Joe Biden  has been trying out several new campaign  slogans of his own to try and help out  the campaign and he's getting mixed  results take a look your generation is  in the cusp of the most incredible  change in world history change only  comes through challenge we don't have  dreams we don't have aspirations  America's future is not as bright as its  past in the long run we'll all be dead  we will not succeed American workers are  part of the problem point of personal  privilege where is Delaware it would be  about a year but I promise I promise  I'll pay you back  [Applause]  excuse me I have a cold I'm sorry  [Applause]  what's your favorite which one's your  favorite a it back just I love that